en france journée de manifestation
aujourd'hui à l'appel de plusieurs
syndicats une mobilisation nationale
pour défendre les salaires et les
emplois et pour s'opposer aux réformes
du chômage et des retraites 160
rassemblements sont prévues sur tout le
territoire à paris la manifestation
partira en début d'après midi place de
la république on y retrouve tout de
suite notre reporter estelle farges
[Musique]
bonjour estelle grande journée de
manifestation aujourd'hui un peu partout
en france les salariés qui manifestent
pour la départ dont les manifestants qui
manifestent pour la défense des salaires
l'intersyndicale qui entend aussi de
protester contre eux les réformes
exactement magali à six mois de la
présidentielle l'intersyndicale entend
envoyer un signal fort alors vous
l'avais dit il ya tout d'abord la
question des salaires l'inflation qui
devrait s'établir à 2,1 pour cent sur un
an au mois de septembre selon les
estimations provisoires de l'insee et
les bons résultats du cac 40 au premier
semestre ont remis la question des
salaires sur la table c'est en tout cas
ce qu'estime la cgt pour le syndicat
cite la colère et la conscience qu'il y
a de l'argent mais qu'il n'est pas
redistribué en direction des salariés
sont de plus en plus importante et puis
vous l'avez dix ans dans les cortèges
devraient se trouver des opposants à la
réforme de l'assurance chômage qui est
entré en vigueur vendredi et puis il ya
aussi la question des retraites en est
une potentielle réforme qui plane sur la
fin de mandat d' emmanuel macron et pour
le syndicat un point de vigilance plus
globalement à les syndicats entendent
mettre les questions sociales au coeur
de la campagne présidentielle alors
estelle qui sera concrètement dans la
rue aujourd'hui
et qu'est ce qui est prévu à paris
et bien de nombreux secteurs d'activités
qu'ils soient publics ou privés
d'ailleurs devraient être touchés par
cette grève nationale les transports en
commun l'éducation nationale mais aussi
les services publics du côté du cortège
à paris il s'élancera à 14 heures ici de
la place de la république direction le
quartier de l'opéra alors initialement à
les autres les organisations syndicales
souhaité pouvoir défiler jusqu'à la
place de la concorde mais ce parcours a
été rejeté par la préfecture de police
en raison de la proximité de ministères
et de la place vendôme sur le parcours
l'intersyndicale elle avait dénoncé une
entrave au droit de manifester maxi
beaucoup estelle pour toutes ces
précisions sur a bien sûr ces
manifestations donc à partir de 14h sur
notre antenne